pensa tutti ragazzi bevono video sono fa
vj e siccome sono youtuber di ampie
vedute porto cultura su questa
piattaforma del web che ci permette di
condividere i nostri momenti più belli
di porto oggi un videogioco che merita
la visione di tutti voi siete pronti
cominciamo amici miei siamo su babies
per sphaus fire che vi spiego è un gioco
dove tu devi io sono un pompiere e devo
salvare i bambini fermi ma ci sono 21
bambini in casa bene come esposto la
videocamera maledizione si vede in alto
qua che ci sono dei bambini da salvare
io li salverò adesso allora ho questa
cosa che non so come mi dite i tassi per
cortesia baby gone un bambino è morto
come non è che mi riprende che devo fare
qua no scusami bambino scusa l'aspetta e
prendo atto e bambine più grosso di me
come possibile tieni ho salvato un
bambino lo salvarne 20 va bene visto che
a tutti i venti allora usiamo l'ala
questa eccoci spengo le fiamme svengo
tutto bravo fa vj compiere allora
quello che contadino il bambino andato
sto morendo anch'io devo stare attento a
non morire anche io attenzione bambino
bambino posso prendere i bambini e
metterli tutti in questa stanza che
tanto finché stanno qua non succede
niente li metto tutti in una stanza zona
va bene e ti più difficile di dark souls
questo gioco ma mi tutti andati
collicola stanza aiuto come faccia c'è
una porta qui si no bambino ci sono io
ti prendo prendilo l'ho preso aiuto è
considerabile family friendly questo
gioco ci mancano 16 bambini da prendere
ci penso io sto morendo
la casa sa prendo fuoco aiuto
l'arma benissimo l'arma la prendiamo e
la prendiamo spara qua spara bravissimo
la ricarica la riga sono andò a fuoco
sono quasi morto
sono morto porca vacca non pensavo così
tragico sono sincero non pensavo fosse
così difficile quindi mi armo un attimo
di pazienza e facciamo le cose fatte
bene tu sei a posto bambino bene andiamo
con l'arma direttamente apra a salvare i
bambini perché il discorso che li dovrei
mettere tutti nello stesso punto
perfetto riprende i bambini prendi
bambini e metti lo stesso molti bambini
prendili va bene uno alla volta non
importa prendere e metti tutti i top
tutti 18 mai pg giu perfetto va bene
andato non capisco dove ma fa niente
2 occhio che mi sta andando a fuoco un
po di roba devo andare a salvare di
prove ma che al giorno d'oggi è
difficile fare il pompiere si vede no no
no no ai papi o sono morti tutti la
montati qua sotto per salvarli non è
servito a niente
va bene allora evidentemente devo dar
fuoco la roba un po di più perché sono
un casino bambino ti salvo io scherzavo
sei morto ne mancano 12 ho fatto più
occasioni prima per la partita di prima
andata meglio
com'è possibile se io a bagno le cose
che stanno andando a fuoco teoricamente
poi non dovrebbero più andare a fuoco
tali sali prima che l'incendio si
propaghi
ne ho salvato due neo salvati qui sono
morto adesso non uso niente li porto
fuori lancia lybra mente ci sono i tasti
che ancora non ho capito però va bene
non importa da te i quadri quei bambini
che piangono va bene ok
perché poi teoricamente la casa se va
troppo a fuoco crolla quindi
teoricamente io devo salvare la casa
oltre che i bambini perché se crolla
tutta la casa
muoiono i bambini quindi un po difficile
vabbè dai tre navi ha salvati pensa
miglior partita da quando abbiamo
iniziato gioca una gara incredibile cev
e nick è proprio difficile come stiamo
facendo devi devi stare attento che
tutte le cose non prendano fuoco perché
sempre e come faccio no ragazzi allora è
impossibile gestire tutta sta roba
impossibile troppi bambini è impossibile
cioè non posso fare il babysitter è
difficilissimo nella mia vita non posso
fare questo e uno dico io devo tenere le
fondate se non tengo le fondamenta la
casa crolla ma che io posso andare di
sotto anche di forma a v di lì a potevo
inter e la sinistra possa lanciare i
bambini alla finestra non sapevo e vabbè
ma sono feature che si scoprono man mano
insomma io non l'ho fatto davvero qua ce
l'ho già passato ma è tutto a fuoco vivo
niente
continuiamo a questa parte del piano di
qua raga la casa sta crollando
[Musica]
ultimo tentativo ragazzo prova a fare
meglio di 6 ma la vedo dura è allora il
primo è qua fuori perfetto piano di
sopra e molto più accessibile di quelli
sotto 2 perfetto baby 6
sto per eguagliare il mio record questo
la dice tutta
ragazzi se li fate come hanno detto
stavo dicendo stesso probabilmente tutti
o button record ma non è stato
prevedendone anche uno fermi
allora vi devo portare tutti via tutti
maledizione quanto quanto prende poco
sta a casa 5
mamma mia come ho fatto arrivare a 6 è
difficilissimo 6 eguagliato il record
dall'altra finestra all'altra finestra e
ci sono uscito anche di qua seppe grande
non sapevo essere un'altra finestra c'è
un'altra pm va bè sette record va bene
va bene così sono contento dei ragazzi
passiamo a dai verdi a per scherzo go
sempre di bambini ma che oggi si parla
di quello e vi spiego allora c'è questa
giocato due anni fa quasi sono passati
quasi due anni a quando ho giocato c'è
questa famiglia che sforna figli manco
fosse una centrifuga ne fa talmente
tanti che io devo tenerli d'occhio
ok quindi finché loro fanno figli io
devo tener li devo fare in modo che non
si ammazzino capito perché se i figli
vanno in giro rischiano di bruciarsi nel
forno di fare cose devi metterli al
sicuro capito questo cia i baffi quindi
secondo me non è tuo figlio io mi farei
delle domande tipo si può infilare nel
forno cosa che non deve fare e quindi io
devo farli sopravvivere non mi dicono
quanti alla mio record però vabbè ci
proviamo da de boni dai baroni che poi
tratto tutto in questa stanza all'inizio
che si sbloccano pure le altre
sottogioco impossibile allora sono in 41
più carino dell'altro basta che non fate
cagate e io sono contento questa una
caramella la prendete la smettiamo di
fare bambini che poi devo tenere io e li
usiamo questi condo li usiamo noi li
usiamo i condom va bene no questo il
frazer ma sei scemo ma cavolo lavora e
basta
dai fori che fastidio allora il forno il
freezer non devono toccare in questo
momento quindi finché c'è solo questa
stanza ci siamo o margine di tre bambini
come vedete qui in alto possono morire
solo in tre
e vi assicuro che una certa diventa
impossibile però sicuro io non l'avevo
visto ma basta ma guarda il prossimo che
si infila nel freezap l'ammazzo io lo
ammazzo io che cos'è cos'è aiuto dov'è
cos'è a madoff e dove cosa è successo
probabilmente è morto stando al computer
stai a dormire se io li metto nei cosi o
bambini nascosti che non possono farci
niente quindi è molto utile metterli nel
cestino ste cose qua quindi vanno usati
questi così qua teoricamente quando si
toglie un bambino rimetti però non ho
ben capito al computer ci devi stare no
non ci devi stare quindi non ci starà
nel cestino o nel cestino un cestino
matttino il cestino
ok togliti togliti suo gioco vi mette 16
incredibile togliti al computer che mori
basta vorrei video di falli j
la smettete di sfornare figli basta fate
schifo po come fanno a stornare figli si
stanno tenendo solo per mano non è che
non faccio baby sitter si infilano nel
forno si è aperta st polpa dio mio non è
un buon segno raga quando si aprono
porte devi tenere d'occhio più cose
quindi il gioco diventa un casino per
favore prendi bambina mattino li prendi
altro 2020 lo qua
togli bambino nel forno occhio che
adesso possiamo andare a chiudersi a
nell'armadio posso chiuderli perfetto
c'è la lavatrice adesso di bambino qua
bambino guide no non è vero che mamma
mia ragazzi quelli al computer mi fanno
una paura perché non li sento
mentre quando si infila nel forno a
famoso rumore o nel freezer o nella
lavatrice quando si infilano nel nono
quando si filano al computer non si vede
proprio
cioè non si sente quindi non riesco a
capire basta computer non lo puoi
tappare con il problema da altre cose
più o meno si puo chiudere lo sportello
maledizione i bambini nel forno nel
freezer un casinò sta vita maledizione i
bambini nel forno nel freezer un casinò
sta vita madonna ragazzi non posso più
non ce la faccio più sto veramente
diventando computer togliti no
dov'è la vasca da bagno no ma siete
scemi ragazzi la vasca da bagno nord si
è aperta un'altra porta non avevano
anche idea no raga non può morire me
neanche più uno ho perso sennò 30 covavo
fatte arrivare a 42 impossibile
mamma mia come l'ho preso quello della
lavatrice incredibile
ok ok secondo me qualcuno si sta
annegando mammamia meno male che sono
previdente il presidente degli stati
uniti
34 larga attenzione la vasca da bagno
ancora posto no no no allora preso ma
ora che mi sono impegnato ho voi due
la dovete smettere costi bambini basta
ragazzi oggi ho fatto il baby sitter è
stato molto bello mi sono divertito se
però vi sia piaciuto spero che di non
avere figli mycroft di non averne così
tanti ragazzi insomma mi piace scrivere
canale sia ciò che con la bellissima
campanellino elettrici nativity fatelo
però non è che mi ascoltate basta fatelo
perché sennò i bambini schiaccia con
l'aria un po nella valigia schiaccia
hackett e gol e noi ci vediamo come
sempre a robot seguito bei ragazzi
[Musica]